in focus now congresswoman nancy may
south carolina republican member of the
house oversight and veterans affairs
committees we are happy to have her in
focus today thank you congresswoman so
first of all let's just start with what
the president should be saying this
afternoon
well for starters you should not attack
the american people he needs to provide
reassurances to our country
that uh we'll have testing available i i
am very keen on the idea of expanding
testing and having the federal
government provide tests to the american
people i'm worried about the the number
and the amount we're already seeing in
the northeast uh testing sites being
overrun and waiting people waiting hours
just to get the test but that's a good
step in the right direction i would say
but we need to provide assurances to the
american people to the governors to
states that are dealing with omicron and
will in the next few weeks as it makes
its way through our country on how we're
going to handle that and that's
everything from testing to the
availability of vaccinations to the
availability of pp and e and making sure
that the american people have the right
information
and rather than attacking we want to
make sure there's growing trust not
distrust of the government growing trust
in the medical community and doctors
rather than selling the seeds of
distrust that's the kind of message we
should be looking for and i hope to hear
this afternoon look real quickly and
then we'll move to the next thing um
you're with your voters in south
carolina you're talking and listening to
people what has been something that this
white house misstepped on the most with
regard to covid because we now have more
people dying we have less access to
testing i mean it's in some ways we've
gone backwards
right it's been a lot of the i think the
misinformation sometimes misleading
information also the vax mandates
there's enormous pushback in my
community in the state of south carolina
to allow people families businesses to
make these decisions these are decisions
that really should be made at the at the
state local and then personal level
there's been enormous pushback here on
those mandates and the attacking people
who uh are vaccinated or not vaccinated
um it goes both sides goes both ways but
attacking others during this time this
is not you know kobet is not solely in
the united states it's everywhere around
the world and we really truly have to
work together it's been politicized we
continue to politicize it um and that's
i think you know made this getting
through this thing even tougher and
omicron is going to be more prevalent
than ever it's less it sounds like it's
less deadly as far as there are many
yeah there's more breakthrough cases
though with amicron too and we want to
make sure people have the right
information so they can make the best
decisions for themselves so you you just
mentioned something that is so important
it's everywhere it's not just in the
united states so i haven't heard the
president or his team at the white house
taking down the unvaccine countries
where they they don't have access to the
vaccines i mean if you want an even
playing field wouldn't they be according
to the white house the the enemies if
you will
and you know with regard to covet i do
want to get to this
from congressman andy biggs of the great
state of arizona because we're on this
topic and here's what he tweeted and in
terms of his response um
this is sick
biden and his crew want to fear monger
their way into dictating your private
health care decisions we're not falling
for it congresswoman your reaction
well i would agree and i think the vast
majority of americans would agree too
these kinds of mandates scaring people
especially during the holidays christmas
and new year's
to bully them into this is not the way
to go we need to not be attacking the
american people we need to provide
reassurances we need to give them hope
give them information and data to make
good decisions for themselves and their
communities and give states the ability
to manage the hot spots obviously the
northeast where there's more
metropolitan areas right now and it's
going to make its way through the
country and so we need to make sure that
there are reassurances to all of our
governors across the country that the
federal government will provide access
to to testing that they need p p and e
et cetera when this thing hits the fan
everywhere else in the country so that's
what we need to be hearing from
everybody across the board today yeah
you talk about readiness
i mean you're waging readiness less
fight among each other with these
politicians and more readiness and that
takes leadership i i want to get to this
look a lot of parents are really
concerned that they're going to start
putting kids back in virtual and we know
the educational harm and emotional
challenges that that can bring for a lot
of kids washington examiner op-ed reads
this way any state city or school
district that is closing down schools
and forcing children back into the
catastrophe that is remote learning is
ignoring 22 months of data they are
sacrificing children's education on
behalf of the panicked segment of the
population that is afraid to go outside
without a mask on no one is being
protected by shutting down schools and
mandating that children be vaccinated
masked or constantly tested what's your
reaction to that congresswoman mace
i can tell you i've seen it firsthand
the struggles of virtual learning and
how awful it has been for our family and
how my children own children have
struggled so i've seen the struggle
firsthand
we don't want to see the federal
government do blanket lockdowns or
anything to that nature it really should
be up to parents on how uh their kids go
to school not up to anybody else i can
tell you i've already had a conversation
with my kids who uh during delta variant
i sit in the school in masks i've got
one kid that's still wearing a mask i've
got one kid that will take it off behind
my back but i've already told him i said
when omicron gets to south carolina
again and we have a prevalence of this
variant you're going to school in kn 95
masks because those offer greater
protection than surgical masks or
medical masks um so that they can be
protected i'm i'm already having these
conversations with my kids i i don't
want to see them in virtual learning i
do want to keep them healthy
we're talking about washing hands again
we're doing all the things that we need
to be doing and limiting uh big events
and those sorts of things we're we're
making those steps and making those
decisions and we're able to as parents
we should have the ability to do that
for ourselves and our kids so what
you're talking about is just having a
choice to get your household ready to
send to school rather than somebody
shutting it down and and forcing you to
become the teacher again um you would be
much more equipped than i it was a
struggle science was hard the first time
and then this time around good to see
you i can't even thank you so much
congresswoman mace we appreciate your
time and your expertise today